- ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
- NO!
- SERIOUSLY, YOU'VE GOTTA
COME BACK IN THE BAR RIGHT NOW.
- YOU COME BACK IN THE BAR!
- MEGAN, I DON'T EVEN
[bleep] KNOW CLAIRE!
- YEAH, RIGHT!
- I'M SORRY!
YOU LEFT YOUR JACKET!
- YEAH, WELL,
WHY DON'T YOU GIVE IT
TO YOUR NEW, FAT,
UGLY GIRLFRIEND?
- I HAVEN'T EVEN MET HER YET!
- WHATEVER!
- YOU LEFT YOUR JACKET,
MEGAN!
- OH, THROW IT IN A RIVER!
- WHY WOULD I [bleep] DO THAT?
- I DON'T CARE, I'M OVER IT!
- FINE!
[sighs]
GOD.
MEGAN!
- LEAVE ME ALONE!
- YOUR JACKET, THOUGH!
- NO!
- SERIOUSLY, MEGAN!
- YOU START BUYING DRINKS
FOR EVERYBODY
AS SOON AS SHE COMES OVER.
I MEAN, WHO DOES THAT?
- MEGAN,
COME BACK TO THE BAR!
- YOU'RE LITERALLY AN ASSHOLE!
- HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
I CAN'T BE AN ASSHOLE.
I GOT ARMS AND LEGS AND A HEAD!
- WHERE'S MY JACKET?
- I HAVE YOUR JACKET!
- FINE.
- DO YOU WANT IT?
- NO!
- YOU KNOW WHA--
- EAT IT!
- WHY WOULD I DO THAT?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M NOT FOLLOWING YOU ANYMORE!
I'M DONE!
- FINE! I'M OVER IT!
- FINE!
MEGAN, COME BACK TO THE BAR.
- NO!
- MEGAN! MEGAN! MEGAN!
- UH-UH! NO! UH-UH!
[boat whistle blows,
bell rings]
- MEGAN, DO YOU WANT
YOUR [bleep] JACKET?
- NO!
- SERIOUSLY,
COME BACK TO THE BAR.
- YOU GO BACK TO THE BAR.
- I'M GONNA THROW
THIS JACKET IN THE WATER.
- OH, NICE.
THAT'S REALLY NICE.
- WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO DO,
MEGAN? DAMN!
- KISS MY BUTTHOLE, OKAY?
- GOOD! FINE! FINE!
THEN I'M GOING!
I'M LEAVING RIGHT NOW!
GOD DAMN IT!
MEGAN!
- NO!
- LIKE, SERIOUSLY, YOUR JACKET!
- BUT IT'S YOUR JACKET, THOUGH!
- WHATEVER!
- MEGAN!
- NO!
- I HAVE YOUR J--
I HAVE YOUR JACKET.
- I'M OVER IT!
- SERIOUSLY, MEG--